Okay, I think we're good.
Internet here sucks.
Like randomly drops every couple days
for a few minutes for no reason.
I know what we're going to do. We're
going to do like this. Yeah.
Over.
Going to make this thing. We're going to
squash this a little bit.
I think we're good.
Yeah, we're backstable.
Stupid thing, man.
Hey, Finn.
You've seen the uh some of our latest
stuff, I presume.
RK4 for drone. Awesome. I will review
that shortly. How is the hardware going?
That is the thing I would like to have
figured out is how do we get drone to
fly?
Hey, that guy.
Hey, how's it going?
What's going on? Overview, please.
No, I haven't seen it yet. That guy.
Overview, please. Uh, normally I stream
all my RL dev. Today, I have to make a
poster for the conference I'm presenting
at in a week or two. So, I'm just
hanging out and I'm making this poster
and chatting RL things.
I'm not going to be able to comment
intelligently on a paper I haven't read,
though, man. Is it like a paper I should
read?
Cuz like if you go look at GRPO and like
look at it in the context of the rest of
RL, it's kind of dumb,
right?
Like the fact that nobody tried that
before in LMS is just like proof that
nobody's really doing anything.
What's the combat? It's the
reinforcement learning conference.
I think if I have one extra thing to put
here,
one extra thing to put here, maybe.
Amazing ride. All right, I'll check it
out at some point.
What else do I put on um puffer.ai? What
else do I put on from here?
There anything else I have that I can
like put that I'm obviously forgetting
from the rest of this.
You froze for me.
Uh, refresh shouldn't be unless it
dipped for a second, but I'm doing a
stable 6K at the moment.
I could just put this here, but
I will be meeting at uni all next week
to get it finished. Awesome. At the for
grammatic controls, but a couple final
things. Awesome. Let me know if you guys
need help. I I very much want to see
this stuff on real hardware because like
also if this works then this is going to
be confirmation that our sim tore real
stuff's reasonable and uh we're going to
want to try like know arms and other
stuff as well
Uh oh. Am I
Are we frozen again? Let me see. No, it
says we're not dropping frames.
We're fine.
Solve some GRPO problems with LML LMS.
SP
uh that guy if it requires sampling a
ton of rollouts like a ton of uh
rollouts from the same data like GRPO
does, then no, it's kind of useless.
like they basically are just burning
massive compute because they have no
data. And like even if we're looking to
scale compute, it's not a super
attractive way to do it because like the
base case of we want this to work well
with infinite data and limited compute
doesn't work. the same sequ
that's what it does in GRPO, right? is
they take the same like the same
prompter or what they like roll it out
several times.
Want to teach someone with no coding
experience how to code properly? What
would be your suggestion?
Read my article.
I wrote an article for this.
Where is it?
I literally It's here.
People asked me for like a from scratch
guide. So, this is it.
These are like all my best tips. And
then there's even stuff for ML in
general.
learning basic and it's all in there,
man. If you just read that guide, what
do you do when you don't feel like
studying? Well, luckily, I don't
typically have to do much studying
anymore, but when I don't feel like
working on a thing, I go run. I go
powerlift. If I'm totally burnt out, I
play some games.
suggest how to code properly.
Better for someone no experience.
Well, it sort of does, right? It doesn't
This doesn't give you a less the that
one doesn't give you a lesson plan, but
it does tell you very clearly like the
common pitfalls to avoid, right? You
start by just learning basics from
anywhere and implementing some very
simple projects.
And you start with something you can
build in a couple hours. Build something
you can build in a couple of days. as
you build up to bigger things and then
it kind of tells you where to go from
there.
I think network is important to land a
job. Do not ask me for traditional
career advice. I have the least like
traditional I do crazy things, right?
It is definitely a way to go, I will
say, but it is not like the cookie
cutter way to go.
life goes off fast. What do you think
about Nvidia CEO?
Yeah, just ignore all that.
If you replace all programming, you
solved AI. So like you've basically
replaced everything.
Like, but yes, listen to the people
whose direct financial interest it is to
tell you the thing where like they have
literally trillions of dollars staked on
poster seems cool for someone who just
kind of crazy stuff. Hopefully
All right. Something like this, I think.
Let me see if I can clean this idea up
as best as possible. And we'll see
whether this makes um
see whether this makes good sense or
not, right?
Oh, you know what I should do?
Wait, I guess the aspect ratio can't be
the same, right? I was thinking if I
could literally just make this our
business card, right?
Okay.
And did they give you the pixel ratios?
Okay. So, it's 3.14x2.2
safe area.
What if you implement something huge on
this library to make it seen in the
community? Like implementing alpha fold,
not reinforcement learning.
Not reinforcement learning.
We're implementing all sorts of crazy
stuff, man.
Like, have you seen the growth recently?
Like, whatever we're doing now is
working quite well. It just it takes a
little while. But here, let me show you
the growth on this.
So, we just hit 3K stars this past week.
This is the growth.
Um, 3K stars
just for comparison.
So this is Torch RL. They also have 3k
stars. A little bit under actually.
Let me give you a comparison here.
So these guys, this library started
before Puffer and uh we just passed them
and they have the Meta brand backing
them.
So the growth is very good. It just it
takes a while. No.
You don't just have you don't build Rome
in a day.
It doesn't have 8K concurrent viewers.
It has 8K views or more. Like some of
them will get 20,000 views but not 20K.
Like if you have 8K confer current
viewers, like that means you're going to
have usually you have a hundred times
that amount of followers.
Like there are literally zero people
working on something like this technical
that have 8K concurrent on anything. I'm
pretty sure there's zero
Yeah. So I got to multiply
the six
This is going to leave too much space if
I do this though. I think it'll be
better to just do two separate things,
right?
be quicker than trying to make them both
fit here.
The edges fit. I think I made the edges
fit but overlapped is what I did, right?
I think I'm probably just overthinking
this, right? It's not that hard to make
a collage. I'm just massively
overthinking. Right.
Do you have any idea for someone who
wants to work on a master's thesis
fields in Oh, okay.
Um,
computer interface and RL that's harder.
That combo is harder. I don't because I
don't know anything about computer
interfaces, right? Like industries we're
looking at. We're looking at logistics.
We're looking at low fidelity control.
We're looking at like the use of
simulators in scientific research more
broadly and how we can like uh change
the way simulation is used with RL.
We're looking at a ton of different
things.
Pretty much anywhere you look, you could
probably find something reasonable.
We just try to like make it cool, right?
not worry too much about
a good
Oh, well, at least in the US, you don't
do a mast's if you're going to do a PhD.
So, I don't Yeah,
typically you just go from undergrad to
PhD or you spend a couple years in
industry and then do a PhD.
We have direct PhD but I came from bio
and neuros. taught better to study AI.
Well,
I don't know how it works in if you're
in the UK or like or EU, but should
probably look into that
because it's like absolutely possible to
do a master's or whatever that's going
to prevent you from even being able to
do a PhD.
Recently came across puffer liib. Very
impressive. Wrote my master about RL for
wildlife sim. Oh, fun. They create an RL
and from scratch and wrap it as
gymnasium. Have run everything locally.
Puffer li would have been useful then.
Yeah, it would have been useful in my
PhD as well, which is why I made it
after I finished, of course. Getting
infrastructure right is hard. It's uh
it's a job in and it of itself. Not like
a part of a PhD. It is a PhD.
Now we have nice things. And now RL
mostly works. Pretty cool.
Finally mostly works.
Trying to think how I even want to do
this. I hate having to do these layouts.
Drives me crazy.
MMO could be more informative. What
would be a more informative picture?
It looks small. You have to keep in mind
that this is going to be 6 ft by 4T.
But like,
you know, you're going to be able to
see.
Oh, it should have been 100%. Hang on.
Yeah. So, this is the scale. You're
going to be able to see very clearly
everything, right?
give you a big corner to do instead
like bigger end
The open AI one is like completely
dated.
Like there are a bunch of agents in this
picture. I guess a lot of them are NPCs.
Why is this so difficult?
I just literally have this little
inspiration right now.
This this thing is too big for how
simple of an end it is for shrinking
this
cool items I can put. I guess I put this
up here.
Pretty fancy.
What's the collage meant to convey to a
newcomer?
Just meant to show off all the
environments.
It's the main thing that we have in
Puffer. Like the majority of the code is
dedicated to these environments.
Like you got to understand that for
research having a bunch of environments
is like very important,
right? Like in fact many of these like
many people who'd want to use puffer
would want to use it for the
environment. That's
literally like a color matching problem,
isn't it?
Try one other thing.
This is not working.
Know what it is about my brain that like
refuses to let me do this basic type of
up.
Let me just try to tile it as best as I
can and call it a day. Otherwise, this
is just going to take me forever
Let's say I want to create a
reinforcement learning model to play a
game. First, I need a way to represent
the state of the environment. Yes.
Thinking of fine-tuning YOLO to detect
objects.
What?
Yeah, you don't you don't need to do any
of that. RL works completely different
from that. So, if you're going to do
something like that, then you if you
have to train on an environment that is
pixels, you train directly from pixels.
You don't need to do object detection or
anything like that. That's going to be
horrendously horrendously slow and
unusable. So if you need to do pixels,
you just do directly from pixels uh for
something like that minus a few specific
applications.
Ideally, what you do is you train
directly from state or partially
observed state. But most of these
environments, you're actually just
seeing like some nearby local portion of
the state data.
And it just simply depends on how much
access you have to the environment or
simulator if you're trying to do that.
You have a ton of guides on the uh on
the website puffer.ai AI as well as on
my Thanks.
Hope you're doing well. Need some help.
Want to implement a turnbased two-player
game and puffer both agents with
selfplay. Yeah, it's kind of a pain to
do turnbased two-player with selfplay.
The turnbased makes it obnoxious.
You can technically do it. Um, we had a
hack that we were using for this. Uh,
and I'm actually I'm going to be doing
this very soon, like possibly even this
week. But basically what we did is we
had these masks. We would hack it so
that you would only take one side's
moves every step. So you get a big batch
of observations, but you'd only use half
of them. Now, it made a mess, though,
because it's very hard to keep things
fast with masking.
So basically, you kind of either have to
hack it via masking.
Yeah, you probably have to hack it via
masking or for now just do selfplay on
something that isn't turnbased
cuz turn-based is just super obnoxious.
Like you can look at 20 like in 20 we
did this with um capture the flag and I
think briefly we did it for connect 4 as
well. It's just it's a pain because like
the infrastructure the way that you
sample for um turnbased is pretty
different from the way that you sample
for everything else if you're doing
selfplay. Material science has been
going. Um I did this stream on Saturday.
Okay, I need to finish some random admin
stuff and get back to it
pretty much.
I am a professional UX UI web designer.
If you need a hand publicizing and show
help,
is there any way that I can do this
that's like less obviously stupid than
what I'm doing now?
Like as you can see even super basic
stuff like I don't know let me just ad
hoc collage like well how do you ad hoc
collage
requires you to have some sense of
spacing Okay.
Like I sometimes hire people for this
type of stuff, but then when I hire
somebody new, it's like half the time I
end up just having to like it takes me
as long as to do it myself.
This has to go underneath, right? Like
doesn't fit here.
Hey, Kvert.
What are you on about?
Doing okay. I'm trying to just I don't
know ad hoc a poster.
At some point I'm just going to be like
done. It's just going to be what it is.
I can kind of fix this if I don't want
the sharp boundaries, right? Is it
better to not have the sharp boundaries
but have it like roughly aligned? It
probably is, isn't it?
like this.
Kind of better.
If I make them the same size, then the
really simple M's are like the same
presentation as the really interesting
ones.
One of my racetracks for the whisker
racer has to be PR.
You got to actually have your end of PR
with baselines to get it into these
things. Get rid of the non-interesting
ones. Yeah, fair.
really one or two that I would want to
get rid of.
2048 is No, Yanick. We have 2048 in
there.
We got 2048
right here.
That actually ended up being a very
useful environment.
Of course, that's getting put in
296. I gotcha. I mean, I got to review
it, right?
Hang on.
Make me do this now in the middle of
this.
You have a base. Wait, do you have a
trained model?
Does it run fast and have a trained
model that is at least decent? If the
answer is yes to those, I will put a
screenshot
and uh I will do the full review after.
Well, it's a cool environment, but do
you have like is it fast and do you have
at least semidecent train baseline?
Those are the two requirements to be on
here.
Actually, Impulse Force is downgraded
for having a kind of okay base.
driving sim down here.
Okay. Um, in that case, do me a favor,
go run eval on it, and when you get to a
reasonable spot, just hit F12, which
will save a screenshot, and stick it in
the Discord. I'll put it on the poster.
Well, it's a cool looking environment
and it would add some visual diversity
to this, right?
I mean, that's good by me.
Where' freaking cartpole go?
Cartpole's like under one of these,
isn't it?
There it is.
This thing. There was a bot in the
Discord earlier that I could not ban.
Like there's some sort of weird exploit
going around where you can't actually
ban some of the bots. I have no idea
what it is,
but yeah, it's jank.
Yeah. Link uh Juarez at puffer.ai.
Um, go ahead like link a portfolio
cuz I am actually that is something that
I uh I have done in the past.
Good to have people on hand for I'm
always very much happy to not have to
spend a day doing
This all the M's or did I forget
anything important?
I know what I want to do with it. Okay.
Yeah, I know how we can fix it up a
little bit.
Just have this be in the center. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. I see it now. I see the
vision.
See what I do with it. But we're going
to have like a running line down here
bottom.
And this goes
in
this is down hereish somewhere. There.
Well, I don't know if this happens to
other people where like you have to do a
bunch of things, but like there's a very
like I'm not terrible at a lot of
things, right? There are a lot of things
I'm actually pretty good at, but like
it's such a hard context switch for my
brain that for instance, like when I get
into hard algorithm dev, I'm not bad at
it, right? When I get into like doing
business side stuff, I'm not bad at it.
But when I have to context switch from
one to the other, I'm freaking terrible
at anything for a couple of days at
least,
or for like actually hard stuff. Context
switching is just brutal. It's like
really brutal.
Is there any way of seeing what M's are
currently being created?
Uh, yeah, there really isn't. And it's
kind of hard to do that in general
because like we kind of just have a big
open source community where people are
doing a ton of stuff. I do have like the
beta page, right, where like we have M's
that are in progress. But then the thing
is we have so many people now that are
just making random stuff. You kind of
just have to look around in the Discord
and if any you see anything recent then
that's what people are doing.
It's very difficult like when you have
this big grassroots thing cuz any system
I make to track that like people aren't
going to actually use consistently.
Want to build RL using CV to play a
platformer.
Self-driving cars. Wise object.
Massively different scale. You don't
have uh a million GPUs to do this. Don't
judge me. I know you're good. It's just
So here, let me show you this.
So if you want to do that, like to play
a platformer, you'd use something like
this.
This is like the fastest out of the box
pixelbased environment for this type of
stuff. Um, you can do it. It will be
faster than anywhere else, but like the
default models for this are about
400 times slower than our statebased
stuff. So, it's like 400 times longer to
do anything versus our statebased stuff.
I It's just the fact that you have to
put all these pixels into a neural
network, right? where state is like a
much more compact representation of
information
We have a lot of new people around here.
No worries. Like you can get uh you'll
be able to get advice and stuff quite
quickly.
How long do you want the gif?
GIF is for other stuff. Convert. I get
me an image first. Just like F12 will
get me an image.
This is a poster. You can also get me a
gift, but I need a post. Like I need to
finish the poster before I do the
presentation stuff. We're not doing
presentation today. So, we're just doing
poster.
put our most impressive environments
look or visually impressive environments
and like spiral outwards I guess
why it would hard be hard to list with
M's. What are some M's that you'd like
to see added?
preferably something simple. Depends on
your experience level, right? Like we've
had people come up with all sorts of
cool things. Like Kinvert just went and
did the highway driving env. I've
actually wanted that for a while, but
like I hadn't thought about that in over
a year until I saw that he was doing it,
right? Um I didn't know that Tetris was
going to look anywhere near as cool as
it does until somebody made it. 2048 I
thought would just be like an easy end
and it actually turned out to be a
pretty interesting challenge for RL. So
like generally there are a few different
categories of things. If you're new and
you just want to have fun and learn some
stuff and then maybe the end of is going
to be super useful. Some of them are,
some of them aren't. Arcade games are
always good. If you have experience in
another area like another field of
engineering or science or whatever, we
love it when people do simulators
uh that are actually industry adjacent
and that's actually how you get involved
with our business stuff as well. Um,
and other than that, let me look at a
whole bunch of these.
We generally like it when there's at
least like some sort of new interesting
aspect of challenge to this. We got one
person doing like six degree of freedom
arm. I don't know if they'll finish that
or not. Uh, I had somebody that's like
almost finished Robocode. I have to
merge a PR on that, which is like this
tank battle environment. If you scroll
through the Discord, somebody's done a
tower defense game recently, which is
pretty cool. There are a whole bunch of
more academic environments that would be
interesting as well, but those sort of
need to be made more by people that um
have like an RL like academic RL
background. Sound.
poster is looking sick. It's getting
somewhere. This was actually a good
suggestion.
Have you thought about doing boats and
ships?
Uh, if somebody actually wants to do
that, then sure. I don't think that
anybody's going to want to like automate
boats in the real world, but like if you
want to do it, like, yeah, you could
probably do something with sailing. I
guess if like somebody was into sailing
to give the title a little bit of
breathing room. Yeah, you're right. Hang
on.
So,
I haven't done the final spacing. Right.
No,
there not a way to do a background on
this thing like see where the box is.
Where's Kverson?
You sent me a
thing in the Discord yet.
Oh, I you did the whole track rendered
from above.
Okay, let me merge. Let me just guess I
merge this and just owe you a review or
whatever.
Hang on.
Not mode seven, but not very fast. What
do you mean a mode seven?
Oh jeez. This is a this is going to be a
lot to merge, isn't it?
If you kept it clean at least.
Fine.
Love to work on a few bits for puffer.
Absolutely. If you uh if you message me
or link me whatever, then I will take a
look. Obviously, right now I have to
just finish this thing.
Would love to have a designer on hand
who's like reasonable and can
do a design task quickly.
I've had a couple designers who've been
like not very reasonable. Like there've
been people I've had to go back and
forth like 100x with
Okay, against my better judgment, I'm
going to merge this and I'm going to owe
you a full review, Kinbert.
I owe you a full review
instead of telling you to like fix the
stuff and then merge it, but I'm going
to owe you a full review.
Uh, you forgot to PR the weights file,
didn't you?
You forgot to PR the weights.
I gota I have to mess with a bunch of
stuff. I don't think I broke the build.
I think this just my local
I didn't know where to put it. No, it's
in resources. Look, resources. You make
a folder and you put like put it in the
whisker eraser there.
Feel like hearing directly from your
experience could save me a lot of time
compared to just googling things.
Wait, any resources
since you Oh, hang on. Since you have
you're a PhD working, do you have any
advice? Didn't I did I not Maybe I
linked this to somebody else before. I
have literally all of my all of my best
advice in one place because everybody
asks me this. So, I I actually put a
bunch of time into writing some good
articles.
Uh this contains like literally
everything you need to get started. If
you uh if you follow this advice, you
will be competent in reinforcement
learning very quickly.
We'll put this in the chat for you.
Yeah. Add the No, it's not convert. It's
different cuz like Aren't you loading?
Hang on. Maybe I'm wrong.
Damn it. This is why I don't yolo merge
stuff. All right, look. You literally
have right here that says resources
whisker racer whisker racer weights.bin.
And it looks like you updated this.
You update this to be to match like the
obs and stuff because there's no way
that this compiles otherwise, right?
You had to export this file and like not
there.
going to have to be small cuz it's
freaking bright green. I think I might
just have to change the um
colors on this and whatever. We'll see.
and see how big the puffer is that I
have before it starts getting to be low
has.
Okay. So, this is how big the puffer is.
Full res
I don't want to watermark the puffer. I
like the puffer to be big.
Oh, yeah. But this doesn't make sense
because then this puts this above.
Okay. So, we'll do like this maybe.
Interesting.
Too long. I use the restroom real quick
and then we'll uh we'll figure out what
else is missing here. Hate making
posters.
And then I got to prep a presentation
which is even worse. Right back.
A couple really cool MS we have that
nobody finished.
Good to have.
Hey, Snowy. Welcome.
Canva, this is not a presentation. This
is a single image.
The only reason your library is fast
because of implementing MSNC. No, it's
fast because of a lot of other things.
This is just the most visible thing.
fast vectorization, fully reoptimized
training, got rid of the entire modern
RL stack and wrote our own like it's a
lot of stuff
using the algorithm in Python
uh very large batch training with optimi
with PyTorch optimized for like a level
of performance that basically nobody has
bothered to do with a lot of logging and
monitoring for us to track down
performance bottlenecks.
I mean, it's a comprehensive effort to
make reinforcement learning fast,
stable, and sane, head.
Yeah, I do have to prepare a
presentation as well. I guess I usually
just do full slides.
Honestly, I put very little effort into
uh my slides in comparison to the
delivery.
Puffer li accept M's written in C++. Uh
typically we don't accept them as PRs.
Um, you can absolutely write your own
M's in C++, but for our first party
ones, we typically don't because we
would have to like we'd have to redo the
build system. And I also just don't want
to encourage people to be doing stuff in
C++ because it just it creates more
problems with me for me with maintenance
and review because like if C gives you
five ways to shoot yourself in the foot,
then C++ gives you about five million
ways to shoot yourself in the foot. And
usually shoot yourself in the foot means
ship it to me and I have to deal with it
next patch.
Why doing all this? What do you mean?
What do you mean? Why doing all this?
There's a poster.
I think that I should just move some
stuff up to the top, right? Because I
have this stuff on the bottom.
Oh, RLC. Um, so I don't publish anymore,
but I have a like an old publication
from my PhD that I kept updating and
resubmitting and like Puffer finally did
get accepted to something, so I may as
well go present it, right?
A lot of stuff on the poster.
Is this considered a lot of stuff on the
poster? Do you know what research
posters normally look like?
All right. This is what research posters
normally look like. Okay. This is the
This is considered a lot of stuff.
Why C++ makes things worse.
It's not that it makes things worse.
It's just that people over complicate
the crap out of everything when you give
them C++ almost without exception. It's
not like I don't want new devs
submitting me C++ crap that I have to
deal with and debug.
It's just like the thing is it's so so
so much easier and simpler to just do it
in C. Like C++ gives you a lot of ways
to screw stuff up and like not a lot of
ways to make things actually simpler and
fast. Research poster. Yes. Not a
marketing one. Well, it's kind of in
between in the sense that it's a re it's
a conference. Um
yeah, it's it's a conference.
This is mostly just so people come over
and talk though, right? I put the most
amount of effort into my delivery of the
material more than anything.
Any M that uses any Majoko models?
Technically, yes, we have a Majoko
binding and an MJX binding. We also have
a beta binding from Manny Scale and we
did some work with Isaac Jim a while
ago.
Make it work. And now you don't need to
use if you wanted
my own one of the Majoko drone models.
make it work in C, you know. Okay, let
let me clarify something. Our first
party environments that we write are in
C. It's not like we only support C
environments. It's that we only accept
uh like firstparty environments to Ocean
that are where you will have the source
code that are in C. We have bindings for
a whole bunch of external M's written in
a variety of other languages. So what
you would do is you just write a binding
for the existing Majoko stuff. you
wouldn't like try to port it to C or
something crazy. Uh that said, we
actually have our own drone sim that is
in C and it's going to be way faster
than anything in Moko.
We literally train it at like 4 million
steps per second on one GPU.
You came across a C++ program.
How long would it take? Depends on how
good the code is, right?
And C++ integrate. Well, you can
literally write C and C++, right?
Printer ink cost for this poster. I do
this with all my posters. They don't
even charge you by that, man. They just
they charge you for a poster.
He is not fully compatible with C++
anymore. Really?
I don't know who came up with that.
How about Oak camel? Is it a good
language? Work at If you work at Jane
Street. Yes. And not really any other
way.
If you want to hear why we use C, you
can read like some of my my articles on
this stuff. It's just like
people over complicate the crap out of
literally everything. And if I can write
brain deadad code that a first year
undergrad student can read and like edit
and see in a file to make any of these
environments and like what are you doing
getting super fancy, right?
But Jane Street uses O camel because
it's Jane Great.
too big of a margin as well. I could
move this entire thing just down a
little bit, but I don't like that
either.
I think the spacing needs to just be
bigger with everything, doesn't it?
I just do like this.
This comes down to like here.
yes a
uh I suggest you do a reasonable amount
of that
should know what the basic data
structures are where to use them and how
to implement them.
Probably if your goal is to get better
at general programming though, you don't
need to do a bunch of lead elite code
style questions which are less about the
uh which are less really about the data
structures and algorithms and more about
solving exceedingly clever puzzles using
them.
It's a very different thing, right?
Depends what your goal is.
your goal is just to get hired somewhere
as a software engineer then yes
that's a different goal from being a
good programmer
getting hired by a big company doesn't
mean you're a good programmer is your
goal to get hired by a big company is
your goal to be a good programmer what
are you trying to
If the goal is to be a good programmer,
then my guide is a pretty dang good
resource, right?
If you're new, you start off writing
some kind of highle stuff. You write a
few basic things that are going to keep
you interested until you can do like
medium-siz projects. Take you a few days
like you can make something reasonable.
Then you very soon after that go and
learn some low-level dev, right? And you
just iterate on bigger and bigger
projects from there
with like some amount of formal learning
in there.
like things that will not make you a a
great programmer. Uh completing every
single CS course at a top university
will not make you a great programmer. Uh
working at a big company and big tech
for a large number of years will not
make you a great programmer. um doing
the same sort of project over and over
again without like actually branching
out and doing new stuff will not make
you a great programmer, right? It's
mostly about hands-on like some amount
of knowledge of fundamentals plus large
amounts of handon hands-on experience on
a bunch of different problems that have
different requirements
and keeping stuff simple and being
pragmatic throughout.
That is how you get to be a great
programmer.
make money learning system design do.
Yeah. Okay. So, these are two very
different goals.
It's completely possible to get hired at
a very well- paid software engineering
job while knowing absolutely jack [ __ ]
I would suggest like I have most of my
best advice in my guide, right? This is
why I wrote it.
like I would suggest that you read it
and then like then ask me questions
about stuff from that.
If you're asking for like my best
general advice, it's all there and it's
going to be presented in a much more
eloquent form than I can do live, you
know, just off the top of my head while
I'm editing a ridiculous poster.
There's a guide. We'll link it to you. I
mean, there's one for reinforcement
learning and then there's one for
programming in ML.
Here's the programming in ML one.
Read it on the side and if I have any
questions. Yep, that is the best thing
to
Uhoh.
that. Oh, internet's okay.
Just Google being Google
What resources?
Let nurmmo cover the top.
Like go up with this. I could, but then
I have this big gap.
Um I don't have great resources for C
honestly cuz I took CS 107 from
Stanford. It really wasn't great. But
like
the thing is you really like there's
really not that much to learn. Like you
need to know what the stack and heap
are. You need to know what a pointer is.
You need to know a few more things about
like data types and bits and that's
about it.
Really don't need like
people think C is complicated. It's not.
It's easy. I don't use it because it's
complicated. I use it because it's
simple.
I don't use C++ because it's complicated
like simple thing
that neural MMO. Oh yeah, make neural
MMO. I don't know if I can do that. I
think it's going to get low res because
you have to keep in mind this is a big
poster.
Um,
yeah. This is how big it is.
Like, yeah, I think any bigger than this
is going to make this pixelate a lot.
I mean, it's already pixel art. You
can't really scale it super well.
I don't think we want more sentences. I
think
Yeah, it's also a really bad way to
learn stuff, Snowy.
DSA
4:00 a.m. here. Go get sleep.
you have baselines for it.
There a whole bunch of M's that are in
development
that uh
we haven't really had PR yet. In fact,
I'm probably going to take this image
out because I haven't tested it. Visuals
need work. We'll see
a day at day.
Yeah,
running is good at least.
cool.
Yeah, you need to like just need to be
finished and uh
need to like finish in PR the end. So,
when I merge stuff, it gets included.
I probably shouldn't have made an
exception for the racing end, but I
thought the uh the visuals were going to
be more finished.
Yeah, this this is like super bright
neon as well.
of it
needs to at the very least be retouched.
Some up to
this.
Okay. So now what we do is we have a
little bit of space, right?
Do I just write a few sentences?
I put bullets.
I think I just take this and make it
less websitey and more conferency,
right?
No, we do it. Maybe not.
We do.
I'm home from work. The real work can
start. There's no real work happening at
the moment. It is all [ __ ] with
posters.
I have to finish this so I can do real
things.
Yeah, there's a bunch of stuff I got to
finish here.
Probably this is going to get bigger is
my guess.
Just like the spacing is total freaking
mess, right?
This dude over here.
Guys here maybe.
What do we do about this vert? Like this
space here, right?
You'll be attending RLC.
This is literally the poster I'm making
for it right here.
Happy to meet up.
No, this does not look like most of the
other posters, but then again, offer li
does not look like most of the other
libraries,
right?
I think the spacing is screwy. There's
really not much on it.
put this in. Um
this
I just need to like move
ends around a little That
It's just layout at this right.
Will I get it to look less cluttered?
Got to have more margin. I suppose,
right?
Are there any actual playable pixel
platformer games? Use RL or Perl.
I mean, yes, you can do propg gen,
right?
The problem with pixels is you're
immediately taking in the best possible
scenario, you're taking at least an
order of magnitude hit to performance,
probably much more
reinforcement learning is developing
chess and
the task. How do you go about developing
in chessa?
So, uh I I actually don't know what's
being done in chess at the moment. We
have a guy in Puffer Lib who's trying to
get us like a just a fast chess
implementation for pure RL cuz we kind
of want to see what ELO we can get to
just doing RL without doing anything
else. Right.
We would very much like help on that as
well if uh good
state based. We don't have statebased
platformers. No,
I don't know if anybody's done a
state-based platformer yet. You can look
around on the discord. I don't think at
least nobody has submitted one yet
Yeah, you can you can definitely do a
platformer, right? Like we don't have
think we really have any sort of
platformer end
at least not in like puffer and fast.
We can bind procgen and that'll run 100k
fps. Uh but we can't train 100k fps on
pixels.
Yeah. So bet's the one here. Third cure
is bet. He's the one who's doing that.
There you go. This is how all the open
source stuff works. There people
interested in doing things. Yay. I think
done.
I think I just need to tighten up. I
need to like give more spacing and this
will be reasonable.
Try something using buffer and let you
know I'm starting starting here. And we
can try any of our demo, right? You can
see all the different ones we have. I'll
be right back. Let me use a restroom
real quick. And I gota The goal is going
to be to finish this poster in the next
hour. So, at least I have a little time
to do other stuff today. Be right back.
Just need more space around everything.
Is that all it is?
You know what? I see a better thing.
Dang it.
We're going to put
this
S
have to just really quickly around
is going to work definitely time
will make it way less cluttered. So this
goes
here
here.
For pixel platformer, would you advise
ecoentric approach?
Uh, it depends how big the blocks are.
So
you see the 11 by see the 11 by 11 crop
around itself plus maybe like a few
extra small things.
Uh
like
lost the last part of your comment.
Perhaps buffering issues. You play
problems, too. Oh, that's weird. Um, so
yeah, what I would basically probably
do, there are a few different things you
can look at for this.
I'd probably do something like this,
right? You have your platformer
Okay, you make it depends if you want
this to be on a grid or not, right? Like
it'll look better not on a grid, but
it'll be simpler to code as a first
environment depending on your skill
level, not uh if you actually use a
grid. So on a grid, it would be
something like this,
right? Where you actually you have all
the blocks or like the platforms are
made up of blocks. Then you have like
your agent here, which is going to be
like I don't know a fish,
okay? And then the fish sees sees some
sort of block around it.
Sees like this. This
they should the block should actually be
aligned, right?
Um, so it sees some sort of thing like
this. And then it probably also needs to
know like its local position in the
block. So get the physics jumps right.
Something like that.
Otherwise, you're going to have to do
something a bit fancier. It's totally
possible to do it not on a grid. Still
have it make sense. Like you could
literally just if you did it not on a
grid, it would be something like this,
right? And you just have like a normal
platformer. And all you do is um
maybe it's better not on a grid.
Frankly, it'll look way better not on a
grid. Um,
you just give it like the position of
the nearest platforms, right? So, it
knows like
x y and then it gets like dx
dy
something like this. I mean, you can do
it a lot of ways, right?
It'll probably look better if you just
make a normal platformer and then figure
out how to do observations though
cuz when you lock everything to a grid,
everything kind of looks like a toy.
Like you get stuff like this looks
pretty toy.
Yeah, I don't think it'll be that hard.
We've got all sorts of examples of
stuff, right?
I have been known to be wrong sometimes.
So, every so often, it doesn't usually
happen, but every so often I give
somebody like a massively harder problem
than I expect.
I'm usually pretty good,
not always
at picking like appropriate problems for
people.
Yeah, I think something like this will
be better once we have it.
Challenges are good. Yeah, but I'm
supposed to give you Yeah, bet's the guy
I've screwed over more times than
anybody. I've just given him way too
hard problems to deal with. He has
actually done them but it's taken like
an obscene amount of time compared to
what I like was trying to give him a
project you know to go like compared to
the scope of the project I try to give
Yeah, it's very boring until one of
those problems, the easy problems you
zero shots turns out to be a very
valuable problem and then it's very
interesting all of a sudden.
And
I don't know where I got this guy from
at all.
size for the puffers.
Just have to like clean it up a little
bit and we're done. Right. This side's
pretty clean.
much all the ocean m almost all of them
are playable games.
Yeah, I know.
It's really obnoxious.
What is the most basic intro to puffer
lab and RL project you recommend for a
new CS grad with no RL or ML experience
in coursework? I have guides for you. In
fact, I have exact guides for what you
want to do here. Go to my articles tab
on X, read my advice for programming in
ML, read my guide for reinforcement
learning in general
if you follow. Well, this one's more
general. This is just prevent you from
doing dumb things in general plus how to
learn some ML. This is like the step by
step how to get into reinforcement
learning. If you follow this, you will
understand RL uh and you will be able to
contribute productively to the cutting
edge research.
just run out of environments. Did I not
include something?
Why is my MOA screenshot so bad?
I thought I had a better MOA screenshot,
didn't I? Thumbnail kind of just sucks.
I think I go get a better MOA thumbnail
and then I have it be bigger.
Oh yeah, this is way better, right?
Way better screening. So,
I can put this guy
in like a place of greater interest, I
suppose,
over here somewhere.
Maybe that helps somehow.
can go back to like close to it original
size. Right?
Something like this
Why is this
Shouldn't
We do final tweaks on this and I think
we call it. But I think we've got um
got it Done.
Why is it puffer AI? Thank you very
much. That's dated.
That is the old website that points to
the old docs.
fixing.bin issue with bet and link key.
Oh jeez. Yeah, you're supposed to just
be able to export your models to the
binary so that they can go on the
website.
Please do fix that. And then I'm going
to have to do um colors. I think
like bright neon.
You're fixing. Very good.
You fix please.
Okay. So now I can actually like finish
adjusting positions.
Hey,
is this centered? What the hell?
It is.
Yeah, because actually Yeah, this this
right.
No, it wasn't. Okay, there. Now that's
done it.
All right. So, what uh I have a font
that I used to use for everything.
Trying to remember.
I'm going to go pull up like one of the
more recent.
This was Monte
Monserat.
I don't think that's better, right?
But that's what I have it in.
This is worse.
All right. Maybe this is good, right?
Monzerat.
Any other objections? Do we have
objections to the current poster or do I
print it and call today with this
knowingness?
Uh, at some point I must have dropped a
bunch because
says I dropped 27,000 frames at some
point. Lovely.
How far away are viewers going to be?
This is going to be printed six feet
wide.
That's actually a good call, though. I
need to check that it's not like
horribly
Good.
Sure. Nothing is like really pixelated.
Shouldn't be.
No. The graphics all look pretty good to
me.
This thing could be clearer, I think.
Right. Yeah. Literally just this thing
could be clearer.
Oh, yeah. I got to probably fix the QR
codes because this will go to the wrong
thing, won't it?
I gotta love how they um
literally
people spend five seconds AI generating
a garbage app and then it's like yes,
you will sign up for our garbage app.
You can also just put the uh the
singular.
I swear it used to be that the first
link on one of these would just let you
freaking generate the QR codes.
make new PR with minor fixes. Thank you.
Yeah, I got to uh I have to actually
review it.
Be warned though, if you PR things,
sometimes I will just submerge it and
then yell at you when it's broken.
If it breaks, it breaks. We don't break
the pit packages. Okay.
Why the heck is this not
Yeah, this is not like remotely aligned.
Hell did I even do this?
Back.
Okay, this is not terrible. Not
terrible.
Do the final checks on this. I haven't
done any go stupid and then we're submit
it. Sick of dealing with it.
not doing bet. When I make a dev
version, it takes me six months to get
it back into main somehow. So, I'm going
to avoid doing a dev version for as long
as possible.
What is your depth of knowledge in other
fields of deep learning? Well, I started
off in natural language processing and
then I moved to vision, but this was
before transformers were a thing.
Um, generally
it's very very jump around between sub
fields of AI.
Like it would take me two months to be
very competent at just about anything
that maybe diffusion would be a little
bit of a pain. Everything else is like
just ML basics plus being able to do
research plus a lot of engineering.
No, I don't f like I don't follow other
areas, right? I don't follow like what's
happening in language modeling research
because I'm not doing language modeling
research.
Well, yeah. This is what happens when
you do some exercise instead of staying
current on literally everything else
happening in the entire field.
I'm actually injured. I should be a
little bit I should be looking a little
bit better now, but I got a bad knee
that I've been like working around.
Can't squat and I've got a bad shoulder
where I can't overhead press and I have
to bench light.
I had some decent numbers last year.
I got to get myself some PT. It's just
busy.
This is fine, right? I think anything
else here is marginal. Let me just make
sure I didn't do anything done with the
text at children. Yeah, it's a pain.
I really want to get my overhead press
back. Drives me nuts.
banish. That's rough. I got distracted
in um overhead dumbbell press, a
dumbbell shoulder press, my shoulder,
and my knee was just like repetitive
strain from uh running and squatting a
bunch.
Stop going. Ah, you got to Yeah, you got
to go exercise regardless, man.
Got to go.
The running is the thing that's such a
pain in the ass. That's where I get all
my damn injuries, mostly from running.
I was doing marathons last summer,
but um yeah, I haven't been in shape to
do I still do like 10ks, but don't like
I don't even do halves at this point.
A lot of time to stay in that type of
shape though. a lot of time.
All right. Uh, next thing is
cards, I believe.
Don't I already have one of these? Hang
on. I think I probably already have a
business card file that I can just
update.
Oh, wait. It's No, it's good. We got an
hour.
hourish.
Such a [ __ ] day. I basically just
screwed around and made a poster all
day.
Ridiculous.
Super basic poster as well.
I'm sure I'm going to have to spend two
days or so on the presentation. It's
like a lot of time. Why I don't do
conferences, man.
takes forever.
The heck is my business card file?
Who the heck is also on? Uh oh, I guess
this got some attention.
Cool.
uh nothing needed. Let me go see if I
can find the card on the off screen
here.
and make that and uh that'll be it.
We're just going to make that.
How do I keep losing the design files
for the
that message. Trying to get layer war
layer norm working. Hey Spencer. Oh
yeah. Hey Spencer. How's poster? Is this
good enough you think?
Freaking hate making posters. Takes all
day.
It's like for even something super basic
takes all day. Here. Here's a poster.
Um,
yes, it should be applied entity-wise.
You're going to have to add a test to
make sure that it's the same. Actually,
I thought I added layer norm.
I thought I added it and tested it. It
should be applied entity wise.
I'm pretty sure I added it.
Do you have it? Yeah, I added it
recently.
You are open. Thank you. Bet.
Yeah, I still have to do the business
cards. Um
have
Trying to figure out why it's not giving
the right behavior. Poster looks good
somewhere in C. Yeah,
that most likely that
I can just remake it super quick, right?
we have way better environments now to
put on this. So,
this nice
Think if I can put the drone one on
there.
I would like to put um I'd like to have
like a drone thing loaded in before we
do uh we do the drones
Guess I can put the drone thing in
anyways. Yeah, we also have my moa.
That's pretty freaking Okay.
here. And then this here.
Pretty well fits, right?
Why is this like so much easier than the
um
I don't know why this is so much easier
than the other one.
Okay.
Uh, other than the minor packing,
anything else I missed?
Those are all the coolest ones
visually, if nothing else.
Boom. That fits perfectly, right?
Now we've got our drone end.
This is everything then done except um
Oh yeah, there's the other side as well,
right?
This was basically what my card looked
like before. Let me just fix some
was it. Is it Was it literally just
Ariel?
Oh
no. I literally did my card in Ariel,
didn't I?
That doesn't look right.
I hate having to do this stuff. It's
like basic things I forget.
There's space, right? Weird.
Weird. If I Okay,
I think there's a good draft of
everything. I can submit these all to
the print shop later today.
Hey, Spencer, if you're still in here, I
can send you some of these as well.
I wish we did have the uh the drone
model loaded into this is the only
thing. Maybe I'll do that tonight. Just
go get a quadcopter model.
Look way better.
print and take with you. Yeah. I don't
know what's easier if you're going to
get there before I will. I guess I'll be
there probably that first evening
anyways though
before all the major stuff happens.
Yeah. Here's poster. Puffer. Puffer.
Here
are the new cards.
I think that's an upgrade, right? We
have more cool MS to show off, so
they'll be cool looking.
Ah, that's what I forgot to go check. I
kind of just got on stream immediately.
Let me see if I have it on my calendar.
If not, I have to go like actually look
through emails.
Yeah, of course, my dumbass did not
actually put it on the calendar.
if I have confirmation emails.
yeah, I don't know where my flights are,
man. I'll DM you tonight, though, so I
make sure I know.
I got to do a bunch of admin crap
apparently.
I think that's a decent decent chunk of
progress, right? I have poster done.
Got these got all the new M's. I think
what I'll probably do is I'm going to go
to dinner. My family is here for another
couple days. Um going to come back from
dinner and I'm going to basically see
how much energy I have. If I can, I'm
going to see if I can get a quadcopter
model loaded in. And uh if not, then I
guess I'll just print them. But either
way, I got to get these sentin tonight
so that we have them in time.
Yeah, I think that's the goal. I go to
dinner now before I start getting too
tired. That way I actually come back and
do real work later today. Um,
so for folks watching, depending on how
long all that takes, there is actually
some research side stuff that I need to
do soon or actually end side stuff I
need to do soon. Uh, probably tomorrow
is my guess. Maybe later tonight.
Usually this is not do boring
administrative stuff stream. It's
usually do RL stream. But yeah, I
figured that people come by and hang
out, so may as well just stream.
I answered a bunch of RL questions today
as well on stream to be fair. Uh if
you're interested in the actual work
that is usually done around here and
you'd like to get involved,
buffer.ai for all the things
can start on GitHub helps us out a lot
and Discord if you want to get involved
and you can follow me on X to get access
to all of my articles and such for free.
Um,
yeah, I think that is it. I think I'm
getting hungry and I want to go to
dinner. So, thank you folks.